Devon when you first receive a script as
a producer what are some of the things
that you're looking at and need to give
a writer-director feedback on and then
also when you receive a script as a line
producer same thing okay
when I first receive a script I I read
it and way I usually based a job off if
just it's a script is good or if has the
potential to be good and so what we'll
do is if I'm brought on board we will
have what will I worry it will do notes
on it will work with the other producers
and the director to get the beginning
where it needs to be to make sure things
are really flowing smoothly the
continuity is there that's nothing that
doesn't make any sense
and that it's just a good story because
at the producer we want to tell good
stories you know we don't want to tell
bad stories so that's the first and
foremost thing that we look at the
character and the content that's in the
story as the line producer I look at it
and go well what budget do you what
what's the target budget you want to
shoot this at and I will read it and the
first thing I'll say after that is a man
you know that you know yeah just might
close up man it's part of a producer job
dad I'm just messing with you so I don't
like hit line producer I find out what
the what the target budget is and then
I'll read the script and we'll say great
we can actually do this for the budget
you want to do it at or go you can't
make this for this budget or you can do
this for the budget but you're risking
the quality of the production and the
quality that crew is going to be and
you're gonna be there's they're gonna be
mad and make it off it because it's not
going to be the film that you want well
I had that happen on another film and
know we can make it for this and I'm
like you can't you got a guy who like
being lit on fire you got stumps and
every other scene does a car chase I'm
like you can't know you need like
another couple hundred grand
but I cover myself and go we'll make it
work now put it in the email I'm just
stating for the record I said that you
can't do this for that
just for the record so if we go over
it's not on me and of course we went
over and I thought their producer the
the executive producer said this is the
original budget I submitted and this is
the budget that we came in at and they
were like two thousand dollars off so
when they were fine with it but it's
just I think a lot of people write it
you know especially writers they're
people who are writers or directors or
writers and producers and actors they
get some merit in their script that they
don't I mean it's important to take the
advice of someone else and not be so
married to it because people are going
to see things that you don't see and you
know when you hire someone you hire them
for a reason you have to trust them and
listen to them and so that's the
important fact I think even as a as a
writer or director and you bring a
project gives like you have to listen to
your team because they're going to do
what's best there they have your back
you know you can't you can't if you
don't trust if you don't trust that then
you shouldn't be working with them so
that's the biggest thing is just making
sure that it's you know that you've
given everybody what they want even the
investors what they want you give them
the writer what they want you're the
director what they want
there's picture it's just you know it
gets done and that looks amazing cuz you
don't wanna make steel one last thing
you want is an investment put money into
it and then when it's done you go wow
this is a piece of like nobody
wants to do that so like why not do it
right
you